toxic masculinity is one of the most
evil times I have ever heard there's no
such thing as toxic masculinity there's
just literally toxic individuals what it
means to be a man is now being branded
as toxic whether it's being competitive
aggressive we are now teaching boys and
men to be softer they're trying to turn
men into women and I think the reason
they want to do this is because it's the
men that go to war it's the men that
fight the Tyranny it's not women we're
emotionally not resilient or even
physically fit enough to fight the
powers that be it's the men that do that
so when the men are feminized the
government those in charge can get away
with whatever the hell they want to get
away with